of all the species that have ever
existed on Earth 99 of them are gone
most of those were wiped out during what
are known as mass extinction events
since life emerged on our planet there
have been five mass extinctions
sometimes these events last many years
but sometimes a mass extinction can
happen very very suddenly some
scientists think we're on the verge of a
sixth mass extinction others think it's
already begun but the question everybody
asks is is there anything we can do to
stop it
[Music]
okay now what okay
I'm kind of busy here pal then you leave
me no choice what
no you wouldn't I'm calling in my marker
oh come on that that that was eight
years ago huh let's see what your wife
thinks okay fine I'm rolling now give me
30 seconds
[Music]
okay where are you drop a pin I'm in
Doom Tower the Sriracha is leaking back
into the world and the arm but I can't
keep the wards up Doom Tower is falling
and she needs help keeping these bad
guys in here especially the bosses like
the Scarab King
I have no idea what you're talking about
raise Shadow Legends get your butt in
this game pick a champion and help me
out here hold on is this today's sponsor
yep it's a super
super detailed tactical RPG battle
system available on IOS and Android for
free it's got PVE and PVP content I do
like PVP
Oria but
a new Limited
[Music]
limited rate has added some characters
from the show as new playable Champions
one of them heart attack you can get for
free just by logging into the game for
seven days between now and July 24th and
if you join now by clicking the link
it's getting the QR code you'll get a
free starter pack with an epic Champion
Drake and it's cool in game Loop okay
I'm joining now but uh seriously where
are you
foreign
how in the world okay pal hang on I'm
coming first
I'm not I'm not doing that
come on yeah
Yahtzee yeah
yeah Yahtzee
Yahtzee
[Music]
the Earth is always changing there's the
climate there's
excuse me oh I've been hearing this for
years no no that's not what if the
climate gets colder you'll be fine why
is that because you're covered in Wool
oh because
told me that in five years the polar
bears will be sunburned and everything
will be underwater that was 30 years ago
you're missing I can't drive an SUV but
oh sure those big shots can take their
private jets and Davos so they can wag
their finger in my face I'm not saying
electric car it's green okay fine what
do you think the electric comes from the
electric fairy it comes from coal you
want more clean energy build nuclear
plants you're more you're not it's a
scam I can't believe he's still falling
for this my point is man-made or not the
climate is always changing oh okay uh
yes sir yeah I gotta stay off Twitter
for a while that's always a good idea
it's not just the climate of the earth
that's changing but also the core within
the Earth as well as the ground beneath
our feet the science of earthquakes is
called seismology but seismology is not
an exact science
seismologists and geologists think they
know how earthquakes work and what
causes them but they're not able to
predict them with any consistency if
they could they would let's add up the
deaths from three large fairly recent
earthquakes
the 1976 tangshan earthquake in China
the 2004 Indian Ocean earthquake and
tsunami the 2010 Haiti earthquake on the
low end those three events killed seven
hundred thousand people but that number
is probably closer to 1.2 million
let that sink in for a minute it's
important those aren't numbers those are
people they're infants the elderly
entire families in one day a million
people are just gone you would think
that mainstream science would be open to
new ideas that could help predict these
disasters you would think they would
entertain alternative theories that
could save millions of lives you would
think so but you would be wrong the
history of science is filled with
alternative theories that were once
ridiculed but are now accepted the idea
of continental drift was called nonsense
an asteroid impact killing the dinosaurs
was called science fiction at one time
if you said the Earth orbits the Sun the
church might seize your property and
throw you in prison things haven't
changed all that much a mass extinction
is defined as an event where at least 75
percent of species on Earth are wiped
out there's evidence of five major mass
extinctions that have occurred
throughout Earth's history the first was
450 million years ago another was 300
175 million years ago the most
catastrophic Extinction known as the
great dying took place 252 million years
ago during the Great dying a staggering
96 of all life on Earth was wiped out
another event was 201 million years ago
and 66 million years ago was the
infamous KT asteroid impact which killed
off the dinosaurs on average these mass
extinctions happen about every 75
million years while some causes of these
events have been identified some remain
a mystery in addition to the major
extinctions many smaller events have
also occurred for centuries scientists
have been debating what caused these
events and changes to the Earth there
are two camps there are the gradualists
or uniformitarians they argue that Earth
changes occur slowly over an extended
period like mountains being formed
slowly as rock is pushed up from the
Earth's mantle then those mountains are
slowly weathered away by erosion in the
other Camp are catastrophists
they claim that Earth changes happen
quickly and through dramatic events
events like asteroid impacts widespread
volcanic eruptions pole shifts and
massive solar flares in other words the
scary stuff throughout history
catastrophists have been ridiculed by
the gradualists but there's mounting
evidence to suggest that catastrophists
may be onto something researchers like
Graham Hancock Randall Carlson Robert
shock John Anthony West and many others
have presented compelling arguments that
Earth changes happen suddenly rather
than over eons hear what you have to
visualize is a tsunami sweeping over the
land that's over a thousand feet deep
wow
there are recent events that support
these claims in January 2023 seismic
data published by Chinese scientists
hinted at a recent slowdown or even a
halt in the rotation of the Earth's core
the earth's core is huge about the size
of Mars it's made of an inner core which
is mostly solid iron and the outer core
which is molten iron and nickel the
interaction between the inner and outer
core produces a geodynamo which
generates the Earth's magnetic field if
the core slows down or stops the
consequences would be severe
in another episode I described exactly
what would happen there's a link below
but I have to warn you it's terrifying
but after the initial disaster resulting
from a pole shift animals and even
technology could adapt but there is a
theory that the speed and direction of
the Earth's core affect more than the
magnetic field the theory says core
changes are linked to more devastating
events like earthquakes and if this
theory is Right life on Earth is about
to become very different
Jim burkland was a professional
geologist who worked for the United
States Geological Survey or USGS he
became prominent in the 1980s when he
started making specific predictions
about upcoming earthquakes he first came
to the Public's attention on October 13
1989. that day he gave an interview
where he predicted a major earthquake
would hit Northern California between
October 14th and October 21st of that
year while the Bay Area is rumbling with
excitement over the first ever Bay
Bridge World Series the Earth may be
putting on a shell a Towny geologist is
predicting an earthquake to hit the Bay
Area anytime from tomorrow to the 21st
of October it will be the World Series
Quake according to Santa Clara County
geologist Jim berklin the trembler he
predicts could be anywhere from 3.5 to
6.0 on the Richter scale birkeland is
basing his prediction on the unusual
gravitational pull of the moon and earth
birkeland was right the 6.9 magnitude
earthquake occurred on October 17th just
four days later and right in the middle
of Brooklyn's window and right in the
middle of the World Series
hesitation allowing Jose Canseco to
score and he fails to get Dave Parker at
second base so the Oakland A's take take
[Applause]
after that birkeland was told by
government officials to stop making
predictions because he might create a
mass panic at the time he was working as
a geologist for Santa Clara County but
two weeks after his prediction he was
suspended from his job but he didn't
stop making predictions he successfully
called the Northridge Earthquake that
hit San Francisco in 1994 and he
predicted a large earthquake in Seattle
after that he was asked to leave his job
but people were still interested in how
he was making his predictions birkeland
believed that gravitational forces and
tidal stresses from the Moon played a
role in triggering earthquakes his
predictions factored in high tides new
and full moons he also noticed a
correlation between seismic activity and
animal behavior his theory was magnetic
fields fluctuate just before a quake
which causes these behavioral changes
especially in fish Birds dogs and cats
mainstream geologists reject all of this
and say that Brooklyn's predictions are
not scientific they say earthquakes are
caused by pressure within the Earth's
crust when that pressure is released as
energy we get an earthquake but that's
like saying an earthquake is when the
ground shakes it's a description not an
explanation what's causing the release
of the pressure meteorologist Kevin
Martin of the Southern California
weather authority also wanted to know
this answer he thought there could be a
connection between earthquakes weather
and solar activity he made a prediction
in 2009. in fact during the Northridge
Quake of 1994 a large ridge of high
pressure was parked in the exact same
spot one will be during our next Santa
Ana wind event the window for that is
January 9th to the 14th this is exactly
in geologist Jim berkland's window so
any bets on the table for a larger Quake
would be during that window now I'm not
saying my viewers to run because a
Northridge style Quake is coming but I
must say the pattern is nearly identical
to it and if other patterns are any
indication of a quick delivery then
always be prepared in light of Mr
birkeland's window falling in this
weather pattern I have taken the measure
to prepare in Casey Quake hits you
always have to be prepared
Kevin Martin and Jim Berkland were both
right on January 9 2009 there were two
earthquakes in almost exactly the place
where they predicted Brooklyn's model
gained further support as the 2004
Indian Ocean tsunami earthquake and the
2023 turkey earthquake occurred during
full moons mainstream geologists like to
point out that birkeland was
occasionally wrong both in the intensity
and timing of his predictions but he was
also frequently right and how many
earthquake predictions have mainstream
geologists made that have been right
zero zero birkeland success and
mainstream Sciences lack of success
indicates that our thinking about what
causes earthquakes is incomplete if
there are other factors why aren't they
being explored is it because mainstream
scientists are afraid of being wrong or
maybe scientists are afraid of something
else
on September 3rd 2017 the United States
Geological Survey reported an earthquake
with a magnitude of 6.3 not far from a
North Korean nuclear test site South
Korean authorities said the earthquake
seemed to be artificial consistent with
an underground nuclear test North Korea
confirmed that it had detonated a 15
kiloton hydrogen bomb and this came as a
terrifying surprise to the Diplomatic
intelligence and defense communities
would you say it sent Shack waves to the
world I would but this test was a
seismic shift
great oh so this test shook the world to
its core and had other countries quaking
in their boots
I got a few more actually I swear I will
ring here
okay I'll step by step you know I only
do that to see the look in your stupid
face right real nice hey let me ask you
eat it that I'm the fish but you're the
one that keeps taking a bait that's it
no one had suspected that North Korea
had reached that level of advancement
with its nuclear weapons program then
just a few weeks later in October 2017
the entire underground Korean nuclear
facility collapsed after a massive
earthquake more than 200 people were
killed including most of North Korea's
nuclear scientists within a few months
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un said his
country was open to discussing peace
with South Korea and the United States
and the possibility of giving up its
nuclear weapons program in June a new
peace treaty was signed after his
nuclear lab and top scientists were
killed in that earthquake Kim Jong-un
had no choice but to negotiate that
worked out nicely for the United States
but what if the earthquake and
destruction of the nuclear facility
wasn't a natural event what if the
earthquake was caused by a new type of
weapon
for years rumors swirled that the United
States had developed a highly Advanced
Sonic weapon using sound waves it could
super heat the Earth's upper atmosphere
and communicate with military units and
submarines at Sea it could alter the
weather and yes Believe It or Not induce
earthquakes the weapon is known as harp
yes h-a-aarp Audi add the club for old
people no that's something else
tarp stands for high amplitude active
auroral research program it's a program
that researches the ionosphere the upper
layer of the atmosphere which ranges
from about 30 miles to 600 miles above
the Earth's surface according to the
original harp website there is an
emphasis on being able to enhance
Communications and surveillance systems
for both civilian and defense purposes
surveillance using the ionic
doesn't sound good well that's why there
are a lot of rumors about HARP the harp
website acknowledged that experiments
were conducted to fire directed beams of
energy in order to temporarily excite a
limited area of the ionosphere now
disturbing the ionosphere could have
major and even disastrous consequences
for the environment harp was very active
in the days and hours leading up to
Hurricane Katrina making landfall in
2005. hurricanes are energized by heat
the specific function of harp is to heat
or energize the upper atmosphere that at
harp affect the hurricane well we don't
know could it have sure
later that same year harp was intensely
active when hurricane Ophelia started
behaving in strange ways it changed
directions multiple times against all
normal meteorological predictions it was
almost as if something was playing
around with Ophelia to see if they could
manipulate its intensity and direction
in 2008 a rare July hurricane named
Bertha suddenly formed off the coast of
Africa it was a very low-level storm but
then the harp transmitters fired up
within eight hours Bertha went from a
weak category 1 to an intense category 4
storm almost as soon as harp was shut
down Bertha calmed down and weakened
Kevin Martin had already made the
connection between electrical storms
high pressure systems and weather in
earthquake events Jim burkland showed
that tidal forces and gravitational
effects were connected to earthquakes
but could a device like harp be capable
of doing both well that had yet to be
tested until 2008.
Cyclone nargus began just a few days
after harp resumed activity at 5 45 in
the morning on April 27 2008. on April
28th the storm was basically stationary
by April 29th nargas had sustained winds
of a hundred miles per hour and began
moving it turned rapidly Eastward
intensified and reached Peak Winds of
135 miles an hour on May 2nd it made
landfall at maximum strength it
maintained winds of at least 80 miles an
hour for hours before dissipated the
harp energy activity continued for days
it finally stopped late in the day on
May 11th about eight hours later in
Chengdu China there were reports of
strange animal behavior iridescent
glowing clouds suddenly appeared now if
you drew a straight line from nargus's
path as it made landfall you'd hit
Chengdu
suddenly a massive earthquake hit
Chengdu with a magnitude of 8.0 and
caused the chain reaction of explosions
in the Schwann mountains these
explosions destroyed the Chinese Army's
largest Armory and their newest weapons
test bases nuclear facilities that
reportedly included several nuclear
warheads were also severely damaged
after carefully analyzing the seismic
data experts said the energy released
was equivalent to that of an underground
nuclear explosion they claimed that
non-geological shock had occurred at the
earthquake epicenter a non-geological
unnatural over those two weeks the
nargus cyclone and Chengdu earthquake
claim the lives of more than 160 000
people and severely damaged China's
military infrastructure today harp is
still in use and is run by the
University of Alaska Fairbanks but
that's relatively new prior to 2014 it
was under the direct control of the
United States Department of Defense now
all of this is speculation and rumor and
of course the US Military and government
say that harp is nothing more than a
radio tower to monitor the ionosphere
but it costs 300 million dollars to
build in 1993. that's almost 700 million
in today's dollars
Rich for a radio tower it sure is
there's so much more to talk about
regarding the Heart Project and it needs
its own video so if you'd like to see
that let me know in the comments now
whether by controlling the weather or
deploying nuclear weapons the human race
certainly has the ability to destroy all
civilization on Earth but even with all
that technology and Firepower it's not
enough to kill off 75 percent of all
life on earth a true extinction level
event of that magnitude is not going to
come from here it's going to come from
out there
there are a lot of interesting numeric
coincidences in astronomy for instance
the moon's diameter is 2160 miles that's
just the right diameter and the Moon is
just far enough away to create nearly
perfect solar eclipses
2160 Years also happens to be the exact
length of each astronomical age in the
procession of equinoxes Earth cycle of
procession The Arc around which the
North Pole wobbles moves about one
degree every 72 years this completes a
full cycle called the gray ear or the
cycle of procession in 25 920 years or
about 26 000 years according to best
estimates the sun resides 26 000 light
years from the center of the Galaxy one
orbit of the solar system around the
center of the Galaxy takes about 260
million years what we see are called
decimal harmonics of the number 26 over
and over again now most scientists would
agree that these numbers are meaningless
they're just a coincidence but what if
they're not what if they're trying to
tell us something very important about
our future
there are a collection of experiments
that may show that these numbers have
some kind of special meaning when
physicists can explain things seen
through telescopes theories have to be
created some of these theories are based
on math and can explain quite a bit but
sometimes the math doesn't work and the
theories get more creative one example
of this is the phenomenon of dark matter
the idea of Dark Matter comes from
scientists who agreed that they found a
connection between mass the physical
stuff and gravity but a problem began
when they started looking at other stars
and galaxies and got clearer and clearer
images there just isn't enough stuff to
create enough gravity to hold everything
together galaxies and solar systems
should be flying apart based on all the
energy and momentum they're generating
so instead of Simply abandoning the idea
that there was a direct connection
between mass and gravity they came up
with a new idea Dark Matter the gravity
is obviously out there so all this
missing matter must also be out there
it's just invisible we can't see it it
with any type of instrument
s none and there are plenty of
experiments that show there are other
forces at work in the universe that
mainstream physicists aren't accounting
for in the days before communication
satellites shortwave radio was crucial
for long-distance communication
shortwave Transmissions are high
frequency radio signals that can be
bounced off the Earth's ionosphere those
signals can bounce over and over again
covering large distances this is called
signal propagation and this allows
operators to talk to each other all over
the world the radio Corporation of
America or RCA notice that the quality
of shortwave Transmissions changed quite
a bit depending on Sunspot Cycles the
more sunspots the more the magnetic
field of the Sun seem to interfere with
shortwave Transmissions when the sun was
quiet shortwave radio was and is much
more reliable now during World War II
the potential Communications blackout
that sunspots and solar storms might
cause was of great concern for the Armed
Forces they can't plan a major offensive
assault against the enemy if there's a
chance your comms might go down so a
radio engineer at RCA named John Nelson
was asked to come up with a method of
predicting when the storms would occur
what Nelson discovered was a surprise he
found that radio interference Rose and
fell not just with the Sunspot Cycles
but also with the Motions of the major
planets in the solar system this was a
revolutionary idea his study found that
the relative positions of the gas giants
like Jupiter Saturn and Neptune seem to
have the most dramatic effects on the
signals you forgot one but I guess giant
you forgot one
Uranus has got a lot of right it's a gas
ice giant like Neptune you don't want to
forget Uranus please don't what don't be
shy about Uranus be proud of Uranus stop
it hey did you know that you could fit
63 Earths inside Uranus
64 of you relax that's enough
okay okay okay okay okay stop I'll stop
thank you consider all the jokes about
Uranus behind you
oh
it is worthy of note that in 1948 when
Jupiter and Saturn were spaced by 120
degrees and solar activity was at a
maximum radio signals average of far
higher quality for the year that in 1951
with Jupiter and Saturn and 180 degrees
and a considerable decline in solar
activity in other words the average
quality curve of radio signals followed
the cycle curve between Jupiter and
Saturn rather than the Sunspot curve
Nelson concluded that while sunspot
activity did have an effect on the
quality of shortwave radio signals the
locations of the planets had a far
greater effect now this shouldn't happen
there's nothing in mainstream physics
that can explain this not gravity not
magnetism nothing Nelson's research gets
even stranger not only do planets have a
major influence on the energetic output
of the Sun that influence changes
depending on the planet's position
relative to the Sun and each other and
at what precise angle well in 1951 Time
magazine article described it like this
New York looking for some correlation
between the Magnetic storms and the
positions of the planets he found that
most of the storms took place when two
or more planets were in what he calls a
configuration that is with angles of
zero degrees 90 degrees or 180 degrees
between the lines connecting them with
the Sun the more planets involved in a
configuration the more serious the storm
is likely to be during the Great
magnetic storm of July 1946 for instance
three planets the Earth Jupiter and
Saturn were in a configuration and three
others Mercury Venus and Mars were also
in a critical relationship
but what the article did not talk about
was the fact that these configurations
as Nelson called them worked out exactly
with what are known as specific aspects
in astrology what you mean like
horoscopes and stuff yup Nelson showed
that when two planets are lined up with
the Sun but separated by 180 degrees
this is called an opposition in
astrology if they're at a 90 degree
angle to each other it's called a square
when the big gas giant planets were
either in opposition or in a square
there would be major disturbances and
storms coming from the sun when the
planets were at 120 degrees to each
other or 60 degrees to each other the
sun was much less active this is not
what RCA the US government or anyone in
the science Community wanted to hear
despite the validity of Nelson's work he
was attacked people claimed he got the
math wrong however these arguments have
not held up well over time and no one
has ever repeated the study to try to
disprove it but since the 1950s Nelson
theories about solar activity being
linked to planetary alignment had been
95 percent accurate mainstream
astronomers who study the sun can't even
come close to this number the resistance
to Nelson just as to birkeland and to
Martin is probably because of the
implications of his work if Nelson is
correct then that means that astrology
is real or at least has a basis in fact
for describing the behavior of
electromagnetic waves and given that
every thought in our minds is nothing
more than an electromagnetic signal the
position of the planets might actually
have an effect on our thoughts and
emotions so does the position of the
planets explain the mass extinctions
that happen on Earth at regular
intervals no to kill off most of the
life on Earth we have to think bigger
since Neptune was discovered in 1884
astronomers noticed the outer planets
have strange orbits it's as if there's a
large object that we can't see that's
tugging on them it was thought that
maybe there was a large jupiter-sized
planet in the far reaches of the solar
system or even Beyond recent papers have
used the term Planet X or planet nine to
describe this theoretical object it's
become associated with everything from
the sun's dead twin to a massive brown
dwarf star a brown dwarf is kind of like
a cross between a star and a planet it's
much bigger than a planet but it doesn't
get hot enough to ignite nuclear fusion
in fact a brown dwarf has been linked to
zechariasis planet Nibiru
exactly another theory about a far
distant object in the solar system is
the Nemesis theory in 1984 two
geologists released a scientific paper
titled periodicity of extinctions in the
geologic past in it they looked at
geologic fossil evidence of extinctions
taking place over 250 million year
period or one galactic year what they
found was evidence that during that
period large-scale extinctions took
place on our planet on a regular
repeating basis and that the interval
between the extinction events was 26
million years Bingo astrophysicists
began to wonder what could cause such a
cycle they eventually settled on the
idea that our solar system is actually a
binary or two-star system the sun they
speculated orbits a dead companion star
or a brown dwarf that is way out in the
Kuiper belt but the Kuiper belt is
similar to the asteroid belt but it's
way way bigger and there are hundreds of
millions of objects in the Kuiper belt
they range in size from small ass droids
all the way up to small planets Pluto
for example is a Kuiper Belt object
beyond the Kuiper belt is another region
called the Oort cloud and the Oort cloud
contains trillions of objects and the
thinking was that as this dead star
orbits the sun it Disturbed the objects
in the Kuiper belt and the Oort cloud
and these objects are then flung to the
inner solar system and to Earth on a
periodic basis once every 26 million
years the name that they gave this dark
star was Nemesis all this was pure
speculation with very little evidence to
back it up until 1982.
thank you
apparently NASA has known about and been
searching for this object for a long
time in a 1982 science digest article Dr
J Allen heineck wrote about the search
for Planet X included a diagram that
suggested the planet was probably a
brown dwarf star that was 50 light years
away that would give it a 13 000 year
orbital period meaning every 13 000
years it would come into alignment with
the Sun the earth and the galactic
center in January 2015 Caltech
astronomers provided evidence of a giant
planet in the outer solar system
according to astronomers Planet 9 is
expected to be many times the size of
Earth and orbit the sun far beyond
Neptune the astronomer claims that
there's only a 0.4 chance that planet
nine does not exist despite it never
being seen so if these large objects are
out there and if Nelson's theories about
planetary alignment are correct then
when all these objects come into
alignment the ripples through space-time
could make earth literally tip out of
balance oh well that's one
possibility but throwing asteroids at us
would be much worse but now we have
something even bigger to worry about the
Radcliffe wave
this doesn't have anything to do with
Harry Potter testing is spelled as it it
does not ah the Radcliffe wave was
discovered in 2020 it's a massive
structure of gas dust and stars that
stretches almost 9 000 light years
across the wave rides up and down
through the galactic plane meaning that
sometimes it's above the plane of the
Milky Way galaxy and sometimes its
objects are below now no one understands
how it was formed why it's shaped like a
wave or how it's even held together once
again gravity is insufficient to explain
it from our perspective it's in the
direction of Orion and about 400 light
years away now that's an incredible
distance but it is close enough to
speculate how it could affect us in the
future we do know for a fact that our
solar system does interact with this
massive Radcliffe wave structure in fact
we can go back and see that we pass
through the Radcliffe wave about 13
million years ago and will pass back
through it 13 million years from now
again this is evidence that we are on a
26 million year cycle the exact size
linked to mass extinction events okay do
you add the number 26 is starting to
freak me out a little well fortunately
the next event isn't due for 11 12 13
million years or so so we don't have
much to fear with the big event but what
about the smaller events that happen in
between the big ones you would think
that all this would get scientists
interested in looking at all these
coincidences whether it's an Extinction
event or just an earthquake you think
they'd be interested in knowing when the
next one is coming but they're not why
is that yeah
why is that
something seems to be going on with the
Earth it may be natural cycles problems
with the Earth's core or maybe something
external linked to a part of space we're
flying through or it could be a new
science that we aren't seriously
studying the question is why not the
answer to that question is the answer to
lots of questions ego money and power
there's a reluctance in the mainstream
scientific Community to put out new
ideas that challenge the accepted belief
systems of the community that pays for
their grants remember we did an episode
not long ago that proved that most
scientific grants come from large
corporations and those corporations are
essentially buying science they want
scientific results to support their
businesses and their products for
government funded grants same thing the
government wants studies done that
support the current agenda that's the
money concern now the ego problem nobody
really wants to take a chance on a new
idea look at the scientists who go
against the mainstream they're often
ostracized and ridiculed sometimes they
lose their job jobs like Jim burkland
scientific breakthroughs don't come from
The Establishment they come from
Mavericks they come from scientists who
don't care what people think of them and
there are very few of those in 1958 when
NASA was formed one of the first things
the agency did was commission a study
from a major Think Tank The Brookings
Institute NASA asked them to do a study
on the cultural impact of exploring
space the report concluded that while it
was unlikely that astronauts would run
into ET out there it was very possible
they might come across ancient ruins or
artifacts from an advanced civilization
that had previously visited our solar
system while face-to-face meetings with
it will not occur within the next 20
years that is the 1960s and 1970s unless
its technology is more advanced than
ours qualifying it to visit Earth
artifacts left at some point in time by
these life forms might possibly be
discovered through our space activities
on the Moon Mars or Venus
that the revelation of higher more
technologically advanced life in the
universe might actually result in the
disintegration of human society it
actually used that word anthropological
files contain many examples of societies
sure of their place in the universe
which have disintegrated when they have
had to associate with previously
unfamiliar societies espousing different
ideas in different life ways
others that survive such an experience
usually did so by paying the price of
changes in values and attitudes and
behavior and who according to the report
would have the most difficult time
adapting to this new reality scientists
the study suggested that a paradigm
shift in Humanity's view of itself and
science's view of their Mastery of
nature could have devastating
psychological effects on the scientists
Stanley Kubrick's film 2001 A Space
Odyssey was built around the Brookings
report how the computer was meant to
represent the scientific Community when
it was discovered that man was not alone
Hal went crazy
open the pod bay doors Hal
I'm sorry Dave
I'm afraid I can't do that what's the
problem
I think you know what the problem is
just as well as I do
science changes very slowly because of
ego money and power scientists egos make
them afraid of being wrong going against
the mainstream will cost the scientists
money like lack of funding or being out
of a job as for power whenever Science
and Technology advances old Science and
Technology becomes Obsolete and less
powerful if life is discovered on Mars
the scientists who predicted that will
gain power the scientists who said Life
on Mars is impossible will lose power
but predicting Life on Mars is a risky
bet not one most scientists would take
but if the Earth truly is changing we're
going to need new science to understand
how dangerous the changes are we'll have
to explore new and uncomfortable ideas
and we have to give those Maverick
scientists presenting those new ideas a
chance to be heard what do we have to
lose well every
special thanks to today's sponsored
chickens quality
Link in the description yes day thank
you so much for hanging out with me
today my name is AJ you know hecklefish
yeah what's popping this has been the
y-files if you had fun or learned
anything do us a favor like subscribe
comment share that stuff is so helpful
and like most topics we cover on the
channel today's was recommended by you
so if there's a story you'd like to see
or learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips and special thanks to our patrons
who make all this possible if it wasn't
for your support there would be no Wi-fi
so thank you if you'd like to join a
great Community Check out the Wi-Fi's
Discord it's free to join but if you'd
like to support the channel for as
little as three bucks a month become a
patreon member or maybe grab something
from the Wi-Fi store hey look if you're
gonna go extinct you might as well go
out wearing a Heckle fish t-shirt that's
gonna do it until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you
foreign